où le mec
merci être là pour écrire la prochaine
saison de vos quesnel alors comment
toutes les saisons je vous rappelle un
petit peu les règles 50 litres de sang
perdu par épisode munitions de pistolets
illimité et bien sûr on n'utilise jamais
le mot zombies des rôdeurs ouais tu veux
dire des sourires des airs en disant
bien désinfecter bons mecs ont disons
lui même entre nous on dise on dit c'est
bien de prince de rôdeur ça qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour le premier épisode de la
nouvelle saison a bouché par comme
d'habitude n'entrant pas la tête
j'ai une super idée j'ai l'impression
que les dragons nous ont suivis dans
tout espérances
thimoté on n'est pas dans game of
thrones là on est dans walking dead j'ai
éventuellement henry pourrait faire une
grosse révélation genre une maladie
grave
c'est une carence en potassium
il me reste ma vie à lire sans problème
thibault tu es tu es viré canon suis
d'accord du coup j'attends la bosse des
joues armen montée vers est direct là
maintenant d'accord alors on change pas
des trucs qui marchent dans la série par
exemple le fait que le bruit attire les
zombies tout ça plutôt cool bien sûr ah
oui d'ailleurs moi j'avais pensé à un
truc fait ce bruit se veut attirer les
honneurs saastal arrêté jul non j'aime
bien j'ai fication notre agglo alors
quand un zombie morin humain on regarde
le concept le vin est pas tout de suite
transformé en zombie
ça m'a un petit peu de temps oui bien
sûr d'ailleurs ben j'avais pensé que ce
serait peut-être l'occasion de faire une
scène qui montre que l'amitié est
toujours plus forte que l'épidémie en
tout cas toi et moi on est vraiment deux
frères depuis le début on inséparables
là je pense que ce sera comme ça pour
toute la vie
c'est quoi marche un peu devant un prend
un peu de recul faisons en live mais
attendre mairie tu peux pas dire ça on
est comme deux frères on élit on est
inséparable et en même temps on peut
aussi être deux frères est viré vivre un
peu loin l'autre quoi ouais pourquoi que
sans ça on sait qu comme a pas de quoi
je me permets mais est ce qu'on ne
ferait pas un peu sur la vitesse des
zombies sont pas rapides rapide là j'en
attends je vais arriver une petite
cheminée là à ce que ce serait pas mal
oui
[Musique]
juste à côté
papa
[Musique]
j'ai peut-être une idée pour régler ça
mais je sens que vous avez vraiment pas
aimé ça me déplaît déjà
vous n'avez pas les mecs il nous faut un
truc nouveau là il faut de la fraîcheur
des nouveaux zombies on prépare à voir
des zombies un peu moderne le loser
bonjour moi ça j'ai arrêté
aujourd'hui je mange que des humains
issus de l'agriculture biologique élevé
en plein air à stresser lui avec respect
mais tu manges encore de la viande toi
tu étais pas vg à wes ici carrément
ouais j'ai oublié c'était mon dernier
bon la neige pas pour se diversifier la
fois un nouveau truc un nouveau perso ok
bah dans ce cas on fait comme d'hab et
comme dans toutes les séries ont fait
arriver un nouveau personnage hyper
attachant pour que les gens les marrons
moi j'aime bien ça continue il est
adorable il altruiste
il a construit un pont pour relier un
village à une école toit pour les
enfants il adore les chiots dans 24 ans
n'a qu'une patte cassée mais donc
hyper bien et pas au jort gardes tu m'en
fais huit comme ça hyper adorable et on
les tue alors moi j'avais un personnage
raciste violeur cannibale vraiment le
mec horrible excellent lui on garde en
vie très très longtemps pendant trois
saisons oh de la pression là les
français vont être au taquet pour
regarder chaque nouvel épisode est
fabriqué on a toujours les épisodes un
peu à vrai maintenant à causse est
regardée quasiment simultanés la
prochaine saison donc elle est comment
tu fais le placement de produit du blé
goudé de la réunion réunion aussi
maintenant je me sens un mois si je me
dégoûte pas décrite la rue
bon un nouveau jean ses couleurs mais
lui faut une nouvelle arme fétiche
hyperviolente away genre des pouvoirs
magiques
non donc à imhoff trône dans notre voix
magique non dans walking dead n'y a pas
de pouvoirs magiques pour les voilà
pourquoi tu es reviennent et c'est
mérité
jlassi
sinon on pourrait prendre une batte de
base-ball qu on entoure de barbelés et
genre on lui donne un prénom à la patte
d'oie jours après l'aubade as
c'était prière tu vas recevoir un coup
de la part de gisèle c'est un peu
vieillot ça quand même
tu vas recevoir un coup de la part de
titouan c'est pas très méchant ça tu vas
prendre un coup de jean-luc ça sonne
trop jean luc tu apprendras coup detat
ineris a chaviré
prépare toi à recevoir un coup de
jacques chirac tu ne peux pas mettre un
nom complet bordel et en plus de
président excusez moi je me repérer mais
je me demande quand même comment c'est
possible quand cette saison avec tous
les zombies qui croise il n'est jamais
vu un zombie du genre qui rentrait pêche
sont de vrais rio mec c'est rihanna way
dans l'esprit des fêtes et regarde il ya
michel drucker en zombies mais non tout
ça alors c'est juste michel drucker en
fait amp à son billet alors c'est pas
mal mais il nous faut une fin alors
justement j'avais une idée
ces caméras cachées on a frisé pendant
huit ans le papa tu peux avoir ma femme
indépendante
alors là on a un peu hésité du coup pour
la véracité du truc qu'on allait
jusqu'au bout elle est morte un repas
concours console et à gagner un superbe
aspirateur d'une valeur de 35 ans non
non non archi nul
il faut rester dans l'univers walking
dead autre chose ok j'ai bon c'est une
fin un peu classique mais la fameuse
technique du personnage mystère vous
n'êtes que je suis ce que je suis
c'est quoi votre nom en fait il vaut
mieux que je reste de dos parce qu'à
chaque fois je me retourne et génériques
qui se lancent grosso merdo les gens
verront qui je suis au prochain épisode
essayez juste pour voir je vais essayer
ce héros l'ol je le spectacle je veux
créer une vraie galère pour faire un
énorme cliffhanger foot le personnage le
plus possible de la merde
le plus possible c'est eric qui
s'appelle lionel ne faisait pas tout dit
une carence en potassium dommage j'avais
justement une banane un fruit très riche
en potassium alors au revoir la banane
mais vous êtes qui je suis
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo je me
suis marré à l'écrire et elle a joué
avec une pote julien raf et casa si vous
avez mieux ces concepts un petit peu
nouveau un petit peu spécial mais pas me
dire des commentaires quels sont vos
séries préférées
donc on pourra faire une nouvelle vidéo
sur aubry lancé rien on verra bien et si
ce n'est pas déjà fait abonnez vous à ma
chaîne youtube et on se revoit très très
bientôt pour la mort de l'homme
[Musique]
ça y est je suis mordu je suis un zombie